[Music]
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator.com uk
forward slash tv offer
five leadership hopefuls are whittled
down to two this week rishi sunak and
liz trust will now face six weeks of
leadership hostings where they'll look
to win over tory members to become party
leader and prime minister
which of the two candidates has a better
chance
and will the conservatives be able to
come back together afterwards i'm joined
now by andrew neal spectators chairman
james forsyth our political editor and
katie balls our deputy political editor
great thank you andrew katie and james
for joining us on spectator tv
now the field in the tory leadership
election has been whittled down to two
after penny mordant was kicked out this
week rishi sunak and liz trust are now
going to the membership for their votes
um andrew to start us off um what do you
make of the field so far do you think
tory members have been given a good
choice between sunak and trust
well i think most westminster observers
thought it would come down to richie
sunak and uh liz trust the right core
lessing in the end slowly but in the end
the right coreless round list trusts and
in some ways rishi soon after seen as
the establishment candidate there's
actually
less that separates them than the sound
and fury would suggest
and i guess that the debate now between
the two will concentrate on economics uh
particularly tax because in that area
there are differences between them and
uh but i think it won't just be policy
it also be character and general
attitude i mean it is somewhat
ridiculous that uh
liz truss who voted to remain in the
brexit referendum is regarded as the
staunch brexiteer
and richie sunak who voted to leave and
has always been a leaver
is regarded with suspicion as a closet
remainer
so i think that is a bit strange but i
think that speaks to
liz trust positioning herself as the
insurgent
therefore
brexiteers are associated with
insurgents
and richie sunak is more the
establishment conservative candidate and
the conservative establishment was by
and large for
remains so i think that's what is being
reflected there
and and james it seems that rishi
knights maybe got a bit of a tricky
position now he's doesn't seem to be as
popular with members at the moment he's
only got what maybe 10 days before the
ballots are posted out i mean how
difficult do you think it is for him now
to kind of to come out on top over those
trusts so it is a sprint that he came
out top in the parliamentary rounds but
as you say this round to be more
difficult i think i mean nearly everyone
thinks that he starts behind liz trust
among the members so the question for
him is what can he do between now and
the beginning of august when the ballot
papers
go out to change minds and i think
there's a particular importance now on
that on that first bbc tv debate between
the two of them on monday night i mean
there's also uh particularly importance
on on what policies will she see that
comes out and liz trust did quite a lot
of policy in the parliamentary rounds as
she was trying to to as andrew says
consolidate the right behind behind her
richie's united didn't do as much what
does he do now with the members to try
and and show them what kind of prime
minister he would be because although he
has been the chancellor is obviously you
know the second most senior job in
government because he has been a
minister for quite some time and bound
by collective responsibility there are a
whole bunch of subjects where we don't
know that much about what he thinks now
uh and having known him for a long time
i think he will want to get across
what he thinks on those subjects in the
coming days
and katie coming from it from the trust
sort of camp angle there
what do you think her strategy will be
now do you think she's got to sort of
play it safe for the for the next week
or so or do you think she has to do a
bit more than that
so liz trusts had the trickiest path to
get to the final two in the sense that
there were it was i think it was quite
hard work the whole way through she had
to have lots of conversations her and
her team of brexiteers for the reasons
that andrew has outlined trying to
convince them to back her even when she
got key endorsements such as sireella
braveman telling her erg european
research group backers to back trust
many of them chose to go to kemmie
badenhock and so it meant she eventually
got there but the focus uh in her team
was very much on mps rather than
thinking too much about uh media she's
on her first broadcast interview uh on
thursday and of the entire campaign and
that's also because i think what is
generally perceived to be one of her
weaknesses is media and the first debate
was tricky for her and she is in the
position where she is now the front
runner now she has made it to the
membership stage she has the most to
lose now she has agreed to do at least
two debates and there are hustings but i
think therefore
where team trusts are going to be most
comfortable is putting out her policy
ideas putting out op-eds and actually
being quite careful about how much and
which media she does so not so little
that she can be accused of hiding but i
think rishi sunaka's keen and his team
are very keen to push him to do a lot of
media try and balance liz truss into
doing more they think the way that rishi
cena potentially beats her
is by forcing her to do media liz trust
underperforming and rishi soon after
over performing and and that's the tax
you're going to see from that side
and andrew to stick with the policy for
the moment i mean you mentioned this a
little bit at the beginning but the two
candidates setting out sort of slightly
different economic stalls i think sunac
wants to
trust wants to cut taxes straight away
sunak wants to come to them later after
dealing with inflation um do you get the
sense that one has a bit more
credibility when talking about economics
or do you think there's not much between
them at this stage
um the richie sunic has huge credibility
uh when he talks about economics and i
say that not actually agreeing with
quite a lot of what he's done but he's
hugely credible in the matter of
economics whereas you sometimes get the
impression that this trust doesn't know
what the hell she's talking about
and she talks about the bank of japan
and uh
about 30 billion already being within
the existing envelope of spending you
know by the time she gets to that 30
billion it may not be there just look at
the latest borrowing figures
the the moment that forecast i think is
shot to hell too
so i think that that he has more
credibility but they both have big
questions to answer so
liz truss is the candidate of the right
but she's pushing unfunded tax cuts
uh i mean how right-wing is that i
thought you know the right was meant to
believe in fiscal conservatism and sound
money uh and that you had if you were
going to cut tax you had to cut spending
or to do what maggie thatcher did cut
some tax income tax but raise i mean she
doubled vat
in her first major budget so
you know i don't understand when we're
already running what is it a 2 trillion
plus national debt and still a big
deficit
how it's that right wing and and
conservative
with a small or a capital c to uh
to wish to
basically print money or borrow money to
cut taxes i mean even uh
jeremy corbyn wasn't proposing that and
i think that on
mr sunak's side
he's got some questions too because
at a time
when the forecasts were beginning to
show
that the economy was slowing down this
year and we've known that almost since
the march budget now the bank of england
then the forecast then showed it was
said it would slow down substantially as
the year went on
and monetary policy was being tightened
with the end of the
quantitative easing and interest rates
beginning to rise at last so monetary
policies tightening was it really wise
to then tighten fiscal policy the way
richie sunic did and to increase taxes
going into a recession is that really
wise is that is that really conservative
either and of course he's had to roll
back on some of that by coming back on
the national insurance to lift people
out of lift the threshold
up and to
increase corporation tax but say
there'll be all sorts of alliances so i
don't think he's covered himself in
glory either and i think both of them
have rather serious economic questions
uh uh to to answer in the debate over
the next couple of weeks
um i mean james do you think that's why
sunak isn't doing as well with the
membership now that's sort of that hit
to his economic credibility if you say i
mean traditionally the party are of
sound money you'd think if someone's
preaching fiscal responsibility compared
to the last candidate that they'd be
doing particularly well but that's not
the case i mean do you think that's why
i think it is essentially about whether
the tory party are still a fiscally
conservative party or not liz trust
makes much of the fact that she opposed
the national insurance increase in
cabinet but she didn't oppose the policy
that it was meant to pay for i mean
there is a real danger here for the
tories which is if if the state can step
in so that no one needs to sell their
home to pay for their social care costs
as boris johnson says will be the case
and you don't need to raise any money to
fund that
then
a is that credible
and b isn't their risk that the tories
simply get outbid by labor that labour
tell people that they can have all sorts
of things and look the tories have told
you we don't need to raise taxes to pay
for these things
and katie how do you think trust is
going to respond to that i mean i know
especially on that sort of charge of
fiscal responsibility i know she
mentioned some of this in her interview
with you
yes and in the interview
the first uh
sit down for an interview she did the
contest she laid out her pitch and you
know i picked her well you are
effectively saying you want to borrow
for tax cuts now her response is the
economic growth is the answer and that
would mean that you'll get lots of
things but you're seeing more and more
people saying well what does this mean
for inflation um which economist are you
listening to and it's quite a narrow
pool she has to point to so i think
there will be scrutiny but i think one
of the problems of russia sunak is he
just doesn't sound very positive in his
message so um i i've spoken to mps uh
who ultimately are a little bit
skeptical of some of those trusses plans
to put it mildly but they worry that the
way rishi sooner has pitched himself in
this contest for saying you know don't
believe in fairy tales which initially
worked quite well for him because he was
at the center of the debate all the
other candidates was being pitched
against him in the in the early stages
in these conversations about cutting
taxes um now just reads as though he he
use almost uh just wants to raise taxes
which isn't what he's saying he's saying
he will cut taxes in the medium term um
but i think it's quite hard when you're
going off a candidate like liz truss to
land that message and and so far and
what he's done and the other problem
rishi scenic has is there is a group who
oppose him not because of his economic
message and they oppose him because of
boris johnson many of whom back liz
trust so jacob rees-mogg nadine doris um
and while liz trust says she's not gonna
get engaged in blue and blue you don't
have to look far in her key supporters
who stand behind her in photo ops to
find those who are quite willing to go
on the record and criticize him so i
think that richard c next challenge has
won the economy and how that's landing
with the membership but and also his
past records but two i think you keep
hearing liz trust talk about loyalty and
i think they do think that wherever she
like can you know is experience damaged
relations with the membership is the
fact that he resigned and they think
they can make hay from that
and andrew do you think that sort of
association
with boris johnson for both the
candidates it's gonna be a bit more of a
problem not just with membership but
when then with the wider lecturer
whoever gets elected as in you know both
served in boris johnson's cabinet for a
long time do you think they're sort of
going to be sort of almost tainted with
boris johnson when they finally run
against labor
no i don't think so i i think because
either of them would be so different
from boris johnson
uh that people will come to think it's a
new government
you know john major who took over from
margaret thatcher in 1990
he was so different from margaret
thatcher
that people did think it was a new
government so when it came to the
general election in 1992 when mr major
was up against neil kinnick
the uh and labor your time for a change
is the most powerful political slogan in
any election campaign in the world
but but when it came to the 92 election
two things happened one people thought
there was already a new government in
the poll tax had gone john major was so
different and secondly people weren't so
sure about neil kinner whether he was
really ready for prime time he had come
on by leaps and bounds but there were
still huge doubts as to whether he was
really ready to be prime minister so as
a result mr wade major won a working
majority now if the tourists pick the
right leader this time and they make a
success of it and the economy starts to
grow again and the cost of living crisis
is behind us rather than in front of us
either liz truss or
richie sunic well so it seems so
different from boris johnson that people
once again will think hey there's a new
government already and uh i think a lot
of people will have different doubts but
the same
degree of doubts about kyostarma
this time round as they had about neil
kinnick in
1992 so i think they're still
all to play for but whoever wins has got
to do it right they have they've got a
short window now to get it right they
need to be seen to be different they
need to stamp their mark on it they need
to get some discipline back into this
party again to make it look like a
governing party rather than a kind of
substrata of the oxford debating union
so i think it's you know it's a it's a
it's a tough one to do but but by i
think it is by no means certain that
whoever wins is going to lose at all i
think the conservatives still have all
to play for and kierst armour has still
got to put his mark on british politics
and and james it is a big task ahead of
whoever takes over though with the
economy i mean is there something that
might be a bit of a poison chalice now
with you know inflation above nine
percent this week for example you know
the new prime minister is going to
inherit three crises
an economic crisis an energy crisis look
what's happening this week with
nordstrom one with the russians turning
the gas back on to germany but only at a
kind of trickle um
and obviously you've got a war in a war
in europe going on um and put on top of
that there is obviously going to be a
lot of rancor and bitterness left in the
tory party from the fact that party has
changed leader three times in six years
just look at how theresa may couldn't
bring herself to clap boris johnson as
he departed from prime minister's
questions on for the last time on
wednesday so it is obviously going to be
a very difficult job for whoever comes
in but i think andrew's analysis is
right is one of the reasons i think the
tories did ultimately decide to change
leader is but the next election
it's an uphill struggle but it is still
winnable for them this is not like 1995
when it was quite clear that tony blair
was going to win and the only question
was how big his majority would be this
time around i think that you know but
there is still
a chance for the tories of winning
and katie on those blue and blue attacks
do you think they're going to be a bit
of a problem for the tory party
afterwards i mean there's reports today
that trust is going to be stepping up
the attacks on sunac via proxies and so
on i mean how can the party come back
together after this do you think
yeah i mean clearly when labour have
been watching the debates recently
they've found plenty of attack lines
they can use going forward but then i
mean i think things can change very
quickly
and now i think if we're looking ahead
to what's going to be coming up in the
next few weeks i would expect there'd be
a lot more blue on blue i think that liz
trust and richie ultimately decided to
step away from doing a third debate
ahead of the final ballots but that was
partly because mps were being really
turned off by how vicious it had become
between the pair and it wasn't really
advantageous for any of them to to go
for that i don't they'll be able to
restrain themselves too much going
forward and i think it's an interesting
one speaking to senior tories i've said
you know well who do you think's the
best place to win an election um who do
you think's the best place to lead the
government and actually often you get
different answers um so in terms of
uniting the party
after this bruising leadership contest
which we i think we can safely presume
is going to become more bruising and
before it gets better um actually liz
trust i think is seen as someone who
perhaps be able to lead the government
more easily partly just because there's
so much venom in certain quarters of the
party at rishi soon act amongst the
boris johnson loyalists and some of
which i don't think is justified um but
that's just they've decided that this is
a person they're going to blame for lost
what has happened and that would make it
very hard i think for him in terms of
the day-to-day have you really careful
about how he did that but then the same
people who say this say well but when it
comes to the election would rather have
rishi sooner if we think that he would
fare better with the general public and
the polling points to this and this is
why it's going to be very bumpy period
no matter who takes over when it comes
to those two key challenges
and andrew on that electability question
i mean for all his faults boris johnson
did do very well in the north of england
and you know areas were calling the red
wall at the last election do you think
either the candidates can take on that
mantle and sort of construct the same
electoral coalition that he did
no i don't think they can not to the
same extent but then i don't think boris
johnson could have repeated that act to
the extent that he he succeeded in 2019
i think that
that december 2019 election now looks
suey generous it was a it was a
particular
coming together of various electoral
forces of which brexit was by far the
most important but jeremy corbyn was
also very important too and suddenly all
these red wall seats began to fall uh uh
the conservative way helped by having
boris johnson uh as the and they lost
all these seats i think that if mr
johnson had stayed and was taking the
tories into the next election he he
would lose a number of these seats he
wouldn't hold on to them all i'm not
saying there'd be a wipeout but he
wouldn't hold on to the extent
that he has because
brexit is not the issue it was except
outside the chattering classes you'll
remain obsessed with it uh jeremy corbyn
is no more as a leader of the opposition
um and boris johnson
had remained an incredible vote
generating machine but he was now
generating votes among auntie tories
motivating them to go out and vote
against the tories
that's what happened in the by-elections
so he was a reason to vote against the
tories rather than as in december 2019
to vote for the tories so i think it'll
be much more difficult now
in their own ways they're both
northerners now obviously richie sunic
is very much a southerner but he you
know he represents uh william higgs old
constituency beautiful constituency in
yorkshire it's a very northern
constituency affluent northern liz
trusts as he leads lass and went to uh a
comprehensive there not not the sink
school she's made out to it to be but
actually she was brought up in a rather
pleasant bourgeois leafy suburb and the
school that she went to was actually
quite a high performer who could explain
why she go to oxford uh there so they've
both got northern uh angles that they
can play
but i don't i just don't think
that anybody now look
there is a long-term trend
of which the what happened in december
2019 was a massive jump in that
direction i think that uh
working class and lower middle class
voters in the middle and the north do
not tend to vote conservative whereas
white collar more middle class more
bourgeois metropolitan voters now tend
to vote labor
and that trend's not going to not going
to change you see equivalent trends
in the united states that are upping the
whole demography of elections now i mean
the hue i mean i've just come back from
the united states the huge change there
is this massive move of hispanic voters
to the republicans i mean who would have
thought that just as you would have
thought that all these northern towns
would have gone to the conservatives
they some of them never had before some
of them hadn't for generations so there
are longer-term movements in play but i
think the tories whoever leads them will
have to reconcile that they won't do
quite as well in the red wall as they
did in 2019
brilliant thank you andrew thank you
katie and thank you james
[Music]
you